so I I recently did like a collab for
this like Japanese Channel
um whereas like they were interviewing
me in Japanese and I went to this like
Studio to go do it and it was run by
like Tokyo television or whatever sounds
like a proper production thing
everything it was really cool but like I
walk into the studio and and I can see
the set and it's like a like a long kind
of like semi-circle table with three
seats and I'm in the middle but there's
the huge [ __ ] plastic devices yeah
yeah right like that that's on on TV
yeah and I'm like oh okay I mean well
it's Japanese TV so it's whatever
the problem was for one no one in this
room is wearing a mask
and second of all I walk in and I get
introduced to the host and the co-host
and I just like straight up shake hands
with them none of us wearing a mask and
I'm like so if I can come this close to
someone without a mask and touch them
and then immediately sit down and I'm
protected by these barriers I'm like I
think we're getting things the other way
around like well I think the way that it
in terms of
the way that the thought process is
behind that is that
because like you know there's still
acting shows going on right there's no
dramas yeah um and they're not wearing
masks show they don't have these plastic
dividers yeah they're acting as if like
it's in like a different world yeah I
think the reason why reality shows and
current TV shows in Japan that uh very
like all based on like real things or
reality
I think it's this kind of way of
messaging being like hey we are still
taking this seriously yeah
which but it's like in a pseudo way
because obviously like dramas and stuff
aren't held to that same standard just
because they're like I think it's
because you don't view it as something
that's real yeah yeah exactly but it's
weird because obviously it's real and
these actors are interacting yeah so
it's obviously like people don't
actually care about the precautions it's
like they just want to make them they
want to think that it it's being
considered because like being next to
someone with a plastic divider here in
the same room I don't it doesn't do
anything no it's just all for sure
what are you trying to show you're
trying to show that you're trying to
take kovid like seriously or you're
taking precautions it's like well yeah
you're not really you're kind of
half-assing yeah if you were actually
taking precautions to stop it then you
wouldn't do the show to begin with yeah
signal that you you are still
considering right which is weird but at
that point it's just like you know like
an empty attempt you know it's just like
Yeah Yeah we're definitely making sure
no one's getting sick by putting these
[ __ ] flimsy pieces of plastic that
are definitely not stopping anything
it's also like a prime example of how oh
Japan is quite slow to adopt and then
get rid of things like they were quite
slow to adopt all these precautions yeah
yeah like it did actually take a while
while we were here compared to the
Western World and then now that they're
not no longer necessary but at least not
as necessary we're seeing that it also
is way harder to get rid of something
where people get accustomed to it in
Japan yeah like people out of just pure
comfort and having to deal with this
every day are being much more like
reluctant to get rid of it and these
systems because I don't know if people
necessarily even like them here I I
don't I don't really understand because
a lot of people I've spoke to given
they're probably more foreign leaning
like in terms of mindset they they don't
really like it but also it's it's odd I
think it's not so much a matter of
liking it or disliking it I think it's
just a matter of I think and I don't
speak on behalf of all Japanese people
but I think the general consensus is is
kind of just like well there's nothing
we can do about it like it or dislike it
we have to adhere to it right so it's
like what can we do we I can say my
opinion about this it's not going to
change anything yeah I I honestly you
like don't know because even
pre-pandemic Japan was one of the few
countries that really embraced Mars
culture to begin with you know there
will be people wearing masks even before
the pandemic existed and it was a normal
thing to see in Japan was it as common
no but there was already this mindset
that was ingrained to be like to take
precautions you know wear a mask and now
like after the pandemic that's just
exasperated that idea to the point where
it's become more than just a precaution
but just become a habit I mean yeah
Japan is still you know even before the
pandemic they were still taking like
influenza shots every year yeah like no
one outside of Japan takes him oh no
they uh they do in uh America oh really
flu shots but is it like common place
where it's like it's I think yeah I
think they do it every year yeah really
I think it's I think it's other
countries like at least in the UK and
Australia I don't think we do no but in
America they get flu shots every year
really because we got we got like a
message from our company that was like
Hey if you want your flu shot this year
you can come get it oh and I was like
what yeah I've never had a flu no I've
never taken it yeah what do you mean
like I've been fine yeah but apparently
in America it's you get it every year oh
wow okay I didn't know I didn't know
that either until I was I think I've
taken like flu shots when I was a kid or
something like probably as a kid yes
yeah I'm not sure if it's common in the
UK um I've never heard of like normal
healthy and healthy adults yeah I
thought it was normally for elderly and
then for younger people yeah that's what
I thought as well um but yeah I don't
know I mean the reason why we obviously
we spoke about this so much because it
is just genuinely interesting and we're
living it and seeing it change all the
lack of change yeah the gym stuff is
annoying yeah I really wish yeah because
they they already I don't know about
your treadmills in your gym but they've
like constructed these like plastic like
boxes like they're like covers around
the entire treadmill oh
like a yeah like a it's like something
you'd see out of like a like a like an
infection movie like a pod it's
literally like they've built like a
plastic pod from shower poles and
plastic what the [ __ ] no our one is
literally just the one it's literally
flimsy plastic it's my dream is
literally that and then they make you
wear a mask in it and to be fair like I
said most people I've seen half mess
skin
like they're not doing it uh and I've
never seen anyone get told off for it in
my previous gym this is given this was
like height of the pandemic because you
know sometimes bro you're [ __ ] dying
on that tread oh yeah and you're like
Brian to gasp for air yeah you pull the
thing down one time I was on it going
ham this must have been like 20 20. dude
like tapped me on the back and was like
dude mask put it up and I was like oh
okay sorry and I was like man that sucks
I'm like I can't keep running man
it's like when you breathe in deeply
like the [ __ ] cloth
it's like I you know I think there's
people who are like dude you can't
breathe in this thing that's [ __ ]
you can but when you're running all
right I there is definitely an argument
there yeah when you're trying to get
that amount of airflow I mean I I think
one of the biggest reasons I stopped
going to the gym when was because it
just wasn't enjoyable
yeah so it's just like especially me
doing cardio with my asthma as well I'm
just like it's just it just stop being
like you stop feeling like I was making
progress and you just felt like I was
tortured torturing myself and I was like
a big reason why I just stopped going
and then I was like I'll go in The Mask
mandate is lifted for the gym and it
just if it will ever at this point never
did so I was like it's weird that it's
kind of kept on in the gym I'm kind of
I've genuinely thought the gym would be
one of the first places that they would
stop doing it because like in Japanese
schools and stuff right when they do
exercise they don't have to wear masks
yeah yeah so I kind of thought oh okay
well that's that's like a government
kind of and again that's why it's so
annoying it's like be consistent with
this [ __ ] yeah it's like if you're doing
physical exercise whether it's in a gym
whether it's in a schoolyard whether
it's [ __ ] out on the street you're
just running along the sidewalk it's
either mask on for everyone or mask on
for no one yeah that's right I think you
know it's been kind of frustrating
because at least in other countries us
and the UK it was kind of like on or off
it was like yeah we're telling you to
wear masks yeah or you don't wear masks
or in Japan it's kind of like here you
do here you don't don't do it here you
have to wait for a moment here like the
whole dance of like in Japan let's say
you're walking outside yeah and you know
you don't have to wear a mask outside
and then you can go inside say a
restaurant you have to put your mask on
for like 10 seconds and then you sit
down as you're walking down the moon you
sit down you're allowed to take your
mask off yeah and then it's like okay
what is this
because we all know once you sit down
covert's like oh wait yeah I'll wait
till you finish your meal yeah I don't
know I don't get it again I don't think
any of us are trying to come off as like
complaining about like like I think I'm
I'm happy to comply and wear a mask
wherever is happy to help and stop
spread of it as long as rules are
consistent yeah I just have some goddamn
consistency and make some [ __ ] sense
yeah and let me run without a mask yeah
exactly that's why I've been trying to
like cycle more because I'm just like
dude I'm so done being like doing
exercise inside you've leveled up you've
gone from like indoor exercise to like
now outdoor exercise right but the one
thing that's better about indoor
exercising it's way more convenient yeah
it's easier to keep track of let's say
you know if you're cycling you can't
even like make a route that comes back
to your house yeah or wherever you are
right it's kind of like the Gym's easy
you rock up run the treadmill lift the
rock well that's why I just do weights
at the gym now like if I'm doing just
like cardio stuff I I have a [ __ ]
indoor bike that in my house so I just
I'm on that yeah because we all did our
health checkup recently didn't we I
haven't done it yet you haven't done it
I I missed because I thought okay
because like it wasn't my fault like on
on the [ __ ] company slack it was like
okay you're Joey your [ __ ] one is on
the the 21st of November and I'm like
all right got it nailed it putting it in
my calendar put on both my calendars and
I'm like all right I got this day locked
all good yeah and then I'm like the
night before I was like okay I should
probably open up the the papers just to
you know double check I need a you know
what I need to bring for tomorrow and I
open it up and it's like okay so this is
all your paperwork for your uh Health
schedule for the 20th of November I'm
like oh
that's today
uh that was three hours ago oh no so I I
quickly rang them up and I was like ah
the [ __ ] is this I was supposed to go
today and they were like oh yeah I guess
there was some kind of mixer blah blah
blah so now I'm doing it like three days
before Christmas oh so I'm like that's
good at least it's before Christmas
merry Christmas you have a Christmas
presents yeah your cholesterol is B
Merry Christmas
I'll I'll pray for B and cholesterol
dude I've been on the C train for like
years for cholesterol yeah my
cholesterol's bad oh damn I'm praying I
get a better urine score this time I
don't know how I [ __ ] up my urine it's
annoying because if you see like a C or
D in urine like you see a Cod and
cholesterol you're like I know what I do
yeah I know how to fix this it's a urine
thing testing what is that testing skill
issues
yeah your blood is just built in like I
don't know what that like what are they
testing for In The Blood as well it's
like acidity I think in terms of the
urine what maybe it's like acidity in
the urine yeah right where it's like and
then something to you and at least
there's something to do with your
kidneys and your bladder and your
whatever but yeah it's like at that
point it's like do you drink more water
than anyone how do you have sugar maybe
I drink too much
my kidneys were like yo can we stop
hydrating actually yes I know right it's
come on it's genetics too your parents
or your grandparents could have [ __ ]
you up yeah I'm pretty sure that's why
my cholesterol so hard